i drink like a hundred iced macchiatos a
day and practically nothing else
wow there's a really cool coffee place
jitters
at the steamtown mall you've been there
no
you've never been to jitters ryan you
are so dorky
give me your number so i can text you
um come on
can i have an email address but i just
thought you should know
i think something a little fishy is
going on a little
that little girl is a child i don't want
to see you sniffing around her
anymore this afternoon do you understand
boy have you lost your mind cause i'll
help you find it
what you're looking for ain't nobody
gonna help you out there jesus can come
through that door that's not gonna help
you
if you don't stop sniffing after my
child okay stanley yelled at me today
that was one of the most frightening
experiences of my life
so how are we going to energize our
office
i mean i haven't done anything since
christmas pam
clearly has just given up trying so what
we need to do
is we need to get things going we need
to get percolating a little bit anybody
have any ideas what we could do any
suggestions
yes andy what if we changed our outgoing
answering machine message
so it just had a little more zing and a
little more pep
zing and pep see that's those are the
kind of words we're looking for yes jim
what about if we did an even newer
voicemail message that had
even more zing and pet now we're cooking
i like this
maybe a whole theme like a wrap a wrap
rhyme urban thing an urban yeah stanley
you want to help us out with that
stanley earth is stanley not me yes you
come on stanley put your little game
down and and join the
group no stanley we're having a little
bit of we're alone down
in a brainstorm session dip a stutter
good this is good i'm going to grab a
glass of water
hey what up cynthia
just hang on a second cynthia
well it turns out that terry was already
suspicious because she had caught
stan lee and cynthia a few months ago so
stanley promised
that he would stop and he did end of
story well
not exactly uh cynthia
kept calling him she would not stop
calling him and she was in love with
them oh and get this
cynthia also married so
it is 6 a.m and d'angelo and i are about
to go house to house to give everybody
their dundies nomination certificate
just like the oscars yes
and this happens day every year this
happens you have a lot to learn my
friend
well you know why don't we try it and if
it goes if it goes good it'll be part of
my tradition
why are you even saying that you're
gonna love it
here we go
this way this way
nice house congratulations
yep okay you and pam have both been
nominated for
dundee awards okay
there we go no no she's not here okay
i'm gonna get your cell phone
stay in bed congratulations have you
lost your mind get off my property
before i call the police
all right you got it good leave it at
the door yeah that's fine okay
okay everybody shh what's up
earlier today stan lee sassed me and
toby gave me some suggestions on how to
discipline him they did not work
obviously because they were stupid so i
am now
going to fake fire him
what does that mean it's like a mock
execution
that's not a good idea yes it is a good
idea it's the only possible solution i
have left
well you can actually fire him no okay
i've had enough of you why are you
telling us this because i want you to
behave as if i'm actually firing him
oscar okay michael if you hadn't told us
this
then we would have thought that you were
actually firing i'm not firing him i'm
not
i need you to act like i am firing him
just what i'm going to do is i'm going
to pretend that i'm
firing him and i need you to act like i
am firing him do you get that
do you get it i'm teaching him a lesson
he needs to learn humility
all right that's all i'm okay here he
comes let's just
play stanley may i talk to you for a
second
stanley hudson you are fired
are you serious i am serious we are all
serious you are fired like a heart
attack
you're firing me over three words
have you lost your mind do you think i'm
gonna let you do this to me
i've watched you screw up this office
for 10 years and i'm filing a lawsuit
and i'm going to tell them about every
stupid thing you've ever done up in this
office
all right okay you know what now you
know how i feel
this was a fake firing lesson learned
good work everybody very nice so i'm not
fired
that's it and uh
do you have anything to say to me oh yes
i do
you are out of your damn little
pea-sized mind
what is wrong with you do you have any
sense
at all okay do you have any idea how to
run an office yes
every day you do something stupider than
you did the day before
and i think there's no possible way he
can top that
but what do you do you find a way damn
it to top it
you are a professional idiot hey stop it
okay everybody out who yeah everybody
except stanley
let's go i can't find my glasses okay
you know what why don't you take my hand
and leave them and let's get out of here
okay okay
it is important to be mindful of all
belief systems at our holiday party
i've been here 18 years and have
suffered through some weird thematic
christmases
a honolulu christmas a pulp fiction
christmas
a muslim christmas moroccan christmas
morocco christmas i don't want it
christmas
is christmas it's christmas it's
christmas i got stanley tickets to see
louis black for his birthday
might not have been the best idea i
don't want no quanza reef
i don't need a dreidel in my face that's
its own thing and who's that black santa
for
i don't care i know santa ain't black i
could care less
i want christmas just give me plain baby
jesus
lying in a manger christmas
what's up are you good at jigsaw puzzles
are you kidding me it's all i did every
summer when my brothers were out sailing
but if this is a romantic thing with
gabe i should probably oh
no no no it's not weird at all you have
your new girlfriend i have gabe this is
just his friends
well okay then yes at least until
stanley calms down
don't look i accidentally did a sudoku
you